the coronavirus lockdowns have taken a
lot from us
they've taken people's jobs they've
taken people's
summers away springs they're taking our
fall away they're taking away
our ability to vote in person they're
taking away our ability to go to school
and now my friends they are taking away
our 11 herbs and spices the secret
ingredient
to kentucky fried chicken which you know
when you eat that kentucky fried chicken
what do you
don't just stop at the chicken you you
start on your fingers because
kfc is finger looking good at least it
was
until coronavirus kfc has a big
announcement that's just come out
they are removing for now their
catchphrase finger licking good
you open up so they block it out they
pixelate it
on all of their classic
their their classic buckets and their
advertising material
it's good but the rest pixelated that
thing we always say
[Music]
ignore it kfc tells us for now
this is very sad kfc it's good it's no
longer finger looking good
i really got a kick out of this
commercial uh even though you know how
furious i am at the lockdowns which are
completely based on politics and have
nothing to do with science
i was very upset about this but of
course kfc is not
actually announcing any kind of slogan
change this is a marketing gimmick
to get people like me to talk about kfc
because they are playing on the
coronavirus
lockdowns and i think this is actually a
good thing and i hope more companies
start to do this
because it shows a little levity it
shows a little bit of humor
right it's all pixelated as if it's too
dangerous to even suggest that you
lick the 11 herbs and spices off
of your fingers they're joking about it
it's become a joke the lockdowns have
become a joke
you still have 14-day quarantines if i
travel from california to new york
i've got a quarantine for 14 days before
i can see anybody
what's that based on the cdc the public
health officials no of course not they
don't have any guidelines like that it's
just based on politics
children need to basically become bubble
boy they need to
show up to school when they're allowed
to go to school wearing these big
ridiculous plastic cubes and bubbles and
things
for a virus that none of them are
vulnerable to
a very very like infinitesimally small
number of people
in that age range are vulnerable to it
much more
in much greater danger on the drive to
school or from the flu
or from anything else it's ridiculous at
this point it's only about the election
and even corporate america is waking up
to that a little bit having a little fun
at its expense
so good on kfc i will continue to get
their delicious
fried chicken i will continue to savor
the 11 herbs and spices
even as i eat it off my fingers
when that is over i i hope that kfc is
all right with that something tells me
they are
because they just want to sell some more
chicken they just want to reopen the
economy
and i think all of us do as well
[Music]
you